睫毛弯弯
眼睛眨啊眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯
你的微笑像月弯弯
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
2003年
我的第一场演唱会站在中正纪念堂的舞台上
我以为那是我最大的挑战
结束演唱会之后
我松了一大口气
觉得我应该可以面对接下来任何的困难
一路走来到现在
我越来越明白
当一个歌手每天都要面对不同的挑战
每天都要比昨天更努力
每一次都要有最精彩的表现
谢谢你们
让我可以继续有勇气站在这里
因为有你们一路陪我到现在
现在我要把这场演唱会送给你们
2006年的这场演唱会
我要请你们跟我一起完成这场精彩的演出
我知道我可以办得到
邀请你们为我加油好吗
嗯呐呐呐呐呐呐
哎哎哎哎哎
啊
嗯嗯嗯
keep fit i love
love love
越来越来越
爱爱爱你
啦啦啦
go
不撒不撒风
轻松快乐摇摆
张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海
不撒不撒
把烦恼统统抛开
say yeah
不帅不帅
眼泪放假
悲伤状态
爱靠过来
大声say hi
没有答案就别问
why oh why
相爱就跟上节拍
眼泪放假
悲伤状态
i靠过来
大声say hi
没有答案就别问
why oh why
相爱就把心打开
不再不累
再往前飞
准备准备爱在心扉
呜呜撒呜撒
放轻松快乐摇摆
张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海
不散不散
把烦恼统统抛开
say yeah
五杀五杀
眼泪放假
悲伤展开来
靠过来
大声say hi
没有答案就别问
why
oh why
相爱就把心打开
不累不累
再往前飞
准备准备爱在心扉
哇撒哇撒
放轻松快乐摇摆
张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海
五撒五撒
把烦恼统统抛开
say yeah
五杀五杀
不累不累
再往前飞
准备准备
爱在心扉
哇撒哇撒放
轻松快乐摇摆
张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海
不撒不撒
麻烦恼统统抛开
say yeah
无暇无暇放
轻松快乐摇摆
张开双手
天蓝蓝大海
五杀五杀
把烦恼统统抛开
say yeah
五杀五杀
没事
耶hello
大家好
啊因为接下来这首歌啊
我觉得还蛮符合台南的
因为就是太阳很大啊
所以我们今天下午彩排的时候
让我心情也非常的好
这首歌叫做太阳万岁
太阳万岁
管我们距离有多远
每天都新鲜
想你的时候
抬头看天边
太阳万岁
月过彩虹
到你身边多美
梦想想实现就会实现
早就爱
啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
我闭上眼听风说话
他说被爱的人你也不用怕
我睁开眼睛看着我笑的耳朵下
你的吻是温柔的力量
我小小的
我们的爱像太阳一样喔喔i love
那要万岁
有人距离有多远
每天都新鲜
想你拍拍头
太阳万岁
月色彩虹到你身边多美梦
想想实现
开开就会实现
好棒哦
啦啦啦
我闭上眼轻松说话
他说被爱的人你也不用怕
我睁开眼睛看着微笑的阳光
你给的温暖
把无爱不会照亮
永远围绕在我身旁
太阳万岁
管我们距离幼儿园每天都新鲜
想你的时候
抬头看天边
太阳万岁
越过彩虹
在你身边多美
梦
想想实现就会实现
可是你不要再说
你担心你的背影
我的不同
我很清楚
就像最热烈的阳光
这要万岁
管我们距离有多远
每天都新鲜
想你的时候
抬头看天边太阳万岁
月光彩虹在你身边多美
梦
想想实现就会实现好了
没有抽的人到最后一次了
多新鲜
想着看着天边这次太阳万岁
越过彩虹到你身边做美梦
想想实现就会实现
呀哼哼哼哼
开心吗
哈哈哈哈哈哈
这首歌是用jj林俊杰所帮我写的手表
就让我变成你的手表
贴紧手背听你的心跳
在第一时间陪你快乐夜晚
想你沉沉的睡着
拥有你每一秒
就让我的心为你读研
滴答滴答是我的祈祷
就算是地心引力足够
却挡不住我向爱奔跑
为了你
我做得到
爱吹着我们寻找依旧美好
有你给我暖暖的抱
对我很重要
请我们寻找这一个
刚好都是这三人
12天雨大爱再也停不了
谢谢
就让我变成你的手臂
滴答滴答是我的祈祷
就算是无心引力阻挡
却挡不住
我想爱奔跑
为了你
我做得到
爱陪着我们寻找地球美好
不必给我温暖的拥抱
对我很重要
爱你是我们寻找这一刻
刚好当时这段真是2.1刀
爱再也听不了
依旧没小心哦
有你给我暖暖拥抱
对我很重要
爱我陪着我们寻找这一刻
刚好当时针分针12点遇到
再也停不了
当时针分针12天
遇到爱再也停不了
谢谢谢谢吉祥老师
哈哈哈哈哈哈嗯
我心砰砰跳跳
灵魂快要出窍
这感觉真好
oh
你对着我微笑
温度越来越高
怎么办才好
也不是躲猫猫
小鹿在乱跳
跳上了心扉
心情荡秋千
脸上红苹果滋味真甜美
baby
你是谁
为什么我变成胆小鬼
好喜欢你
却说好久不见
明明才见
第一次念
睫毛弯弯
眼睛眨啊眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯圈
你所谓想象要玩一玩
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
睫毛弯弯
眼睛眨啊眨
心脏的世界变得好好玩
来玩大风吹吹什么
吹一见钟情的声
我心蹦蹦跳跳
灵魂快要出窍
这感觉真好
有你
all right now
谢谢眼神跟猫猫小鹿在乱跳
好恶心扉
心情荡秋千
脸上红停过总归知甜美
北b你是谁
为什么我变成胆小鬼
好喜欢你
却说好久不见你
你才见
第一次念
睫毛弯弯
眼睛眨啊眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯
你的微笑像月弯弯
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
睫毛弯弯
眼睛眨啊眨
心动的世界变得好好玩
来玩大风吹吹什么
吹一寸柔情的神
睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯
你的微笑像月弯弯
气氛好浪漫
需要你的大睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨
心动的世界变得好好玩
来玩大风吹吹什么吹一见钟情的人
睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯转
你的微笑像月弯弯
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨
心动的世界变得好好玩
来玩大风吹吹什么吹一见钟情的人
记住
谢谢嘿嘿嘿嘿
今天开心吗
这边开心吗
好前面开心吗
嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
可不可爱留言
在刚刚回来怎么行
又开始发呆
一
我的最新动态
是不是你也有点小期待
或许我该找个机会试探
看看你的心是否同样一想到你就会嘴角上扬
嘿嘿心情一穿拖鞋逛街
心情安慰
小时长队无所谓无所谓
和你一起画面都很美
星期三笑着流眼泪
心情四点了
相依以为想和你周末约会哇
留言才刚刚回来
怎么醒又开始发呆
我的最新动态是不是也有点小期待
嘿爱
或许我该找个机会试探
看看你的心是否同样一想到你就会上扬
等一下会有一个特别的人哦
心情一穿拖鞋逛街
心情换为小事
吵嘴无所谓无所谓
和你一起画面都很美
星期三笑着流眼泪
心情四天能上依偎
想和你周末一回
耶我有一个人来参与我们的演出
嘿嘿嘿
现场的观众请你跟我登上卫冕的宝座
心情一穿拖鞋逛街
心情和微笑是憔悴
无所谓无所谓
和你一起画面都很美
星期三笑着流眼泪
星期四点冷香依偎
想和你
周末约会我无关
oh yeah
都很美
喔喔喔啊哈
想和你周末约会
右摇左摇右摇左摇
耶
想和你来
谢谢这个送给你
谢谢掌声鼓励耶
接下来要唱的这首歌哈
其实呃是很特别的一首歌曲
这首歌我也很喜欢
叫做丢铜板
下
你送给我99朵玫瑰
也送给我
我爱掉的眼泪
你能带我起飞
也能让其再跌倒受伤
爱上你
就像吃巧克力
苦苦的却又浓浓密密口吃下
全部让我两种味道都满足
像云霄飞车
高低起伏
既害怕
却又像是投入
爱
就是让人快乐
又有一点点想哭
像个热气水
开瓶以后
谁怕慢慢的不再跳动
我还是喜欢在你手中里迷人的甜度
正面是你对我的好
反面是你发过的脾气
爱情就像有同伴苦与乐
一半一半
正面是你要的自由
反面是我要的浪漫
我们的爱
不管谁分身不都一般痛苦一番心思
你送给我99朵玫瑰
也送给我
我爱掉的眼泪
你能带我起飞
也能让其代跌倒受伤
爱上你
就像吃巧克力
苦苦的去弄懂秘密
一颗吃下
全部让我两种味道都满足
相遇
消费就高低起伏
既害怕却又像小投入
爱就是让人快乐
又有一点点小苦
像可乐汽水开瓶以后
气氛慢慢的不再跳动
我还是喜欢在笑容比迷人的甜度
正面是你对我最好
反面是你发过的脾气
爱情就像个同伴
苦与乐
一半一半正面是你要的自由
反面是我要的浪漫
我们的爱不管谁分胜负
都一半痛苦
一半幸福
有你的选择前进
我睡我一天不听睡
正面是你对我的好
反面是你发过的脾气
爱情就像丢同伴苦与乐
一半一半证明是你要的自由
分别是我要的浪漫
我们的爱
不管谁分身不都一般痛苦一番幸福
呜耶耶
你要的自由
我要的浪漫
一番幸福
嗒嗒嗒嘀嗒嗒嗒嗒嗒
谢谢谢谢王心凌耶
等一下哦
这是我们刚刚拍的
要送给谁耶
拜拜
再一次热情掌声
谢谢王心凌好
hello
看你把爱放进我的心里
关上耳朵
我用心在听
你用爱为我打造贴身耳机
看你保持神秘
你还是猜中我的心
播放我的心情
慢慢留个心
我的心里微笑哭泣
放心会有你
贴着心贴的好近
每分钟070.1首歌给honey哥哥传递叫声要多了
更新彼此最新的秘密
爱要随身听
随时感应
多喜欢你叫韩语
甜言蜜语
在我心里爱你当空写如今甜蜜的心
充满惊喜都不会腻
让我往心里
用心为你
那边的朋友哦
会不会唱啊
honey
你把爱放进我的心里
关上耳朵
我用心在听
你用爱为我打造贴身而泣
honey保持神秘
你还是猜中我的心
播放我的心情
慢慢流颗心
往心里微笑哭泣
放心会有你贴着心贴的好近
每分钟零距离准备好没有
第一首歌给honey甜隔空传递架上
跳过了更新彼此最新的秘密
爱要随身听
随时感应
多喜欢你就和你甜甜蜜蜜
在我心里爱你的空虚日记
甜蜜的心充满惊喜都不会
你让我往心里有股心品味你
honey honey honey honey啊
耶耶谢谢谢谢你们
天呐
平常你们今天大家都有带相机
对不对
有平常都是你们拍我啊
今天我可要反派大家了
我看看我的手可以拿多远
我希望我的相机里面通通都是人
好不好
可不可以举起你们的手啊
我蹲下来了
一啊不对
我应该高一点哈
啊没有开闪光灯
再一次哦一
谢谢好
现在麻烦你们拿出你们的相机
因为啊我从来没有看过
就是很多很多台相机一起闪
这么多台一起闪好不好
拿起枪
现在先不要拍
哈喽我数到三哦
请麻烦灯光棒啊
方案我知道3号123
好棒哦
有没有
我在台上看
我觉得很开心诶
就是到处都是光
当然我们现在又要谢谢你们帮我完成啊
接下来呢要唱的这首歌跟光也很有关系
叫做梦的光点嗯
啊
奔跑在人群里面
我看不见
偶尔和孤单遇见
在原地转圈圈
我跟自己面对面
踮起了脚尖
靠近了一点
梦就住在前面
我不管淋湿的脸
用坚定的双眼换一个脚步
欣赏磅礴大雨的阴天
未来还有另一面
能不能看见
靠近了一点
我不再蒙着眼
幸福的起点
幸福的起点有彩虹
花朵铺满在一整片蓝天
不管有多么远
有你在我身边
我追着梦的光点
是因为有了勇气才不怕危险
你的爱没有上限
给我力量
继续往前
我追着梦的光点
请练习站在同一边的起跑线
加速度冲出线
仰起了脸
我们微笑
一起迎接幸福终点
我不管淋湿的脸
用坚定的双眼换一个脚步
欣赏磅礴大雨的阴天
未来还有另一面
能不能看见
抛弃了一点
我不再蒙着眼
明天的笑脸
幸福的起点有彩虹
花朵铺满在一整片蓝天
不管有多么远
有你在我身边
我追着梦的光点
是因为有了勇气才不怕危险
你的爱没有上限
给我力量
继续往前
我追着梦的光点
新练习
站在同一边的起跑线
加速度冲出线
仰起了脸
我们微笑
一起迎接幸福终点
我追着梦的光点
是因为有了勇气才不怕危险
你的爱没有上限
给我力量
继续往前
我追着梦的光点
心连续站在同一边的起跑线
加速度中出现
燃起了脸
我们微笑
一起迎接幸福终点
接下来唱的歌曲啊
我想大家都一定会唱这样
然后一般来讲呢它是我跟大家大合唱的歌曲啊
叫做当你
如果有一天我回到从前
回到最原始的我
你是否会觉得我不错
如果有一天我离你遥远
不能再和你上演
你是否会发觉我已经说再见
快唱完一起唱好不好
当你的眼睛眯着笑
当你喝可乐
当你吵
我想对你好
你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好
当你说今天的烦恼
当你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢你
时空之大
如果有一天梦想都实现
后面的成了永远
你是否还会记得今天加入我们好吗
我们都发觉那这边的呢原来什么都可以
我们是否还会停留在这里
大家一起来好吗
把你的眼睛眯着笑
当你喝可乐
当你吵
我想对你好
你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好
和你说今天的烦恼
当你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢你们
师父知道
也是口气让我想得太多
也许该回到被窝
梦里会相遇
就毫不犹豫大声地说起他
我想对你好
你从来不知道想你
想你也能成为嗜好
啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
我想对你说
却害怕都说错
好喜欢你
知不知道
啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
耶
好棒哦
你们真的太爱你们了
因为太爱你们了
今天其实嗯主要是要唱新歌嘛
对不对
可是因为太爱你们啦
你们有没有觉得有什么歌还是想听的
对不对
是红好吧
既然大家都想听
爱你的话呢
我就要听我的dancer上台啦
然后要介绍这首歌给大家听到
一起唱哦
好爱你
yo yo yo yo cindy
what what what is love me
you cry
baby
what you want with me sing
it
give me your love
you make me sis on the top
耶耶耶耶耶
now now
这个我第一次过打喷嚏
在凌晨03:26
let me sing
let me sing the soul
陪你入睡
no
what is love say
yeah
say
yes
no say
to me
i really do love you
so you
管你出到了个喷嚏
一听就是我在想你
如果半夜被手机吵醒啊
那是因为我关心
常常想你说的话是不是别有用心
越想相信却又忍不住怀疑
在你的心里
我是否就是唯一爱
就是有我常烦着你
so baby
情话多说一点
想我就多看一眼
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
bye
少说一点
想陪你不只一天多一点
让我心甘情愿爱你
完美了
put your hands up
哈哈哈
喜欢在你的臂弯里胡闹
一个世界是一座城堡
在大头贴画满心号
别在手机上对你微笑
常常想我说的话
你是否听得进去
更像神奇
却又止不住笑意
喔哦在我的心里
你真的就是唯一爱
就是有我常烦着你
oh baby
情话多说一点
想我就多看一眼
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
oh bye
少说一点
想陪你不止一天
多一点
让我心甘情愿爱你
接下来要欢迎我的好朋友许玮伦
耶我们一起跳舞
o baby情话多说一点
想我就多看一眼
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
oh bye
少说一点
想陪你不止一天多一点
让我心甘情愿爱你
oh baby
情话多谢谢
当我出手看到怎么唱啊
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
oh b
少说一点
想陪你不只一天多一点
让我心甘情愿爱你
多一点才会慢慢发现她
因为你让我心甘情愿耶耶王心凌
2003~2005辉煌成绩
大世纪
2003年推出首张专辑与主打歌
灰姑娘的眼泪
出道在短短2年之中
从外人眼中的灰姑娘蜕变为今日的销售天后
时间虽短
心灵在唱片戏剧代言的成绩却闪亮耀眼
2年四章
台湾地区突破50万张
销售总数
奠定台湾销售天后地位
来灰姑娘的眼泪就像流星坠落海底
痛到心底
oh baby
情话多说一点
我就多看一眼
多喜欢你叫哈尼
甜言蜜语
我心里爱你
反复学日记
哒哒哒换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒当场表演
活动汇聚将近4万人
证明人气天后
你说今天的烦恼
当你说夜深你睡不着
我想对你说
却害怕
都说错
好喜欢你
结果最大
城门城门几丈高
带着你的爱情
已带马进城堡
在一步步将你围绕
抓住你
你别跑
给我拥抱
两部偶像剧党党收视第一
所有戏剧单位争相邀请戏剧小天后
我不是不知道没有你的日子会有多么煎熬
就算是我傻得可笑
失去当成得到
只要能够对你爱
爱是花儿的芬芳
是蝴蝶的翅膀
是相信的蒲公英
你是他的12大广告代言
弹上广告小天后
啦啦啦嘟嘟嘟噜噜哒哒哒哒哒哒
换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒
2006年
音乐戏剧广告代言持续增加
王心凌在华语市场继续闪耀
专辑里面的歌曲叫做you are my only love
在这里要谢谢很多人呐
谢谢东风卫视啊
所有的工作人员
谢谢台南市政府
谢谢我的家人
谢谢可爱的你们
紧握着你的手
天分了
路口正亮着红灯
说不出一句话
傻傻的站着
你和我
熟悉的这首歌着空气一起分享的呼吸
说完再见以后
说过的爱过的要怎么继续
好想再多一分钟
感觉你的温度
你的味道
你温柔的手在转身之后
发现我的眼睛连着天空
突然下起了大雨
从最初到最后要走到时间的尽头
不变的守候
you are my only love
多记住我们曾拥有海阔天空
放开手才知道冷风吹心好痛
听歌如果会唱的还是一起唱好吗
紧握着你的手
天和蓝
路口正亮着灯
说不出一句话
傻傻的站着
你和我
熟悉的这首歌着空气一起分享的呼吸
说完再见以后
说过的爱过的要怎么解释
好想再多一分钟
感觉你的温度
你的味道
你温柔的手在转身之后
发现我的眼睛看着天空
突然下起了大雨
从最初到最后要走到时间的尽头
不变的守候
you are my only love
要记住我们曾拥有海阔天空
抬手才知道冷风吹醒好啊
从最初到最后
要走到时间的尽头
不变的守候
我们流泪了吗
记住我们曾拥有海阔天空
放开手才知道冷风吹心好痛
i only love
only love
谢谢
刚才还感谢很多人
对不对
还有好多人没有感谢
完了还有兰博舞蹈教室啊
真的很多同事的帮忙
这首歌是怎么知道影在游荡
山野
花闪着微亮的光芒
趁着夜晚找寻幸福方向
难免会受伤
弯弯小路上
不光英在歌唱
星星照亮在起风的地方
月亮诶
乘着微风飘香
未知远方
幸福路也许漫长
难过的时候谁在身边陪我掉眼泪
失败无所谓
你在左右
月光多美
弯弯月光下
我轻轻在歌唱
从今以后不会再背上闭上双眼
感觉你在身旁
你是温暖月光
你是幸福月光
耶可以让我看到你们吗
哈喽后面的有吗
弯弯月光下
蒲公英在游荡长夜华
闪着微亮的光芒
乘着夜晚找寻幸福方向
难免会受伤
换来小路上
蒲公英在歌唱
星星照亮在起风的地方
乘着微风飘香
未知远方
幸福也许漫长
难过的时候谁在身边陪我掉眼泪
是半所谓你在左右
月光多美
弯弯月光下
我轻轻在歌唱
从今以后不会再悲伤
闭上双眼
感觉你在身旁
你是温暖月光
你是幸福
又那那那我啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
我在月亮上歌唱
双眼感觉你在身旁
啦啦啦啦
弯弯月光下
我轻轻在歌唱
从今以后不会再悲伤
闭上双眼
感觉你在身旁
你是温暖月光
你是幸福
月光
谢谢
谢谢我也爱你们
后面的拜拜
再一次掌声
谢谢谢谢王心凌掌声鼓励
社达不要还想不想听
还要不要听
听谁唱
创新营
谁唱
王健林听谁唱
王心凌听谁唱
谢谢大家一起来啊
这时候要喊什么
大家应该都知道好不好
一起来准备123go
开拓开拓开拓开拓开拓
大圣最大声最大声
爱le爱le
爱le 2狗二狗二狗
安口安口安口安口安口安口安口安口安口安口安口安口
给自己掌声鼓励一下
演唱会到最后我有些话想跟大家说
可以可是我怕我无法在舞台上很平静地把这段话说完
我先录了这段vcr
要说出我心里的话
还有我要感谢的对象
我的经纪公司大声音乐的所有同事们
听艺人david老师
小慧姐
思雨哥
还要每天陪伴我的小珍
这回唱片的老板龚喜先生
david哥
董文渊哥
小宝姐
家荣姐
王妈大小姐芬达
还有所有辛苦的同事们
还有所有照顾我的媒体朋友
谢谢你们一路上帮助我
嗯不时的给我支持
不时地帮我打气
你不时地提醒我要更努力
最后当然还要谢谢所有支持我的歌迷朋友们
谢谢你们一路上的陪伴
给我信心
给我力量
这场演唱会之前有一些风风雨雨
我才知道自己并不如想象的这么坚强
很多时候我也会感到挫折
感到害怕
我知道我还要更勇敢
因为有了大家的力量
我才能站在这个舞台
不怕难关的继续演出
我以后一定会更努力的
想到你们
我就觉得我不孤单
不管未来还有多少的挑战
要说你爱我
我知道我会更勇敢的心
再一次要跟大家说声谢谢
谢谢大家
是你们让我有勇气有力量
这场演唱会这首歌是怎么知道
呜呜呜
嗯
在我心里变成了秘密
姐姐你们不要说你爱我
有了你的心里没有这么做
只是勉强的敷衍我
我走不回头
我会清楚明白你要的是什么
无须勉强的安慰我
现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
是爱情的
友情的都可以
真的很感动
做了非常多在台上哭
谢谢你们
你爱我
你想我
如果你的心里没有这么做
只是勉强的敷衍我
我知道了会很难受
我要你默默走不回头
我会清楚明白你要的是什么
无须勉强的安慰我
奇怪的理由
到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
爱情的友情的都可以是我心中的幸福
我知道它苦苦的深深地深深地爱着你
爱情的友情的都可以
那是我心中的幸福
知道它苦苦的多亏
哎呦他在下面想都不可以哭
帮我接唱了好不好
我会好好的
还想想你为何相信时间一直去
天美真美丽
还有我是想着你
我是想着你
一直想着你小姐
你在我心底变成了秘密
到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
爱情的友情的都可以
是我心中的幸福
我知道它苦苦的到现在还是深深地深深地爱着你
爱情的友情的都可以
那是我心中的幸福
我知道它苦苦的给你远方的祝福
我知道它苦苦的
谢谢谢谢我们分分子
谢谢呵呵
没想到会在台上哭
我真的太感动
然后也完成了一个好一个阶段了
这样谢谢哎呦
你们不要再在乎我哭了
阿雷在这里呀
还要谢谢很多人
还有就是我的家人呐
要再次谢谢他们
他们真的很多人大家都来了
还有就是特别从北部来
大家从南部来的
当然还有在台南的你们
谢谢你们也都赶来看哦
还要谢谢台南市政府
还要谢谢东风
谢谢东风幕后的所有工作人员
猴子哥啊
小芳哥啊
还有啊
我经纪公司呃的很多同事刚才都已经谢谢过了哈
谢谢三笠
完全娱乐
还要谢谢朱老师
谢谢兰博舞蹈教室
他们真的很亲意的在帮忙我做这场演唱会
谢谢兰博老师
谢谢所有的dancer
现真的要唱最后一首歌曲了
唱一首歌
我希望你们都可以真的很开心的跟我一起唱好不好
因为这首歌大家应该还算熟悉
叫做大哒哒
呦呦呦
让开心先过
我想向搜寻好天空哦
向前向后转身
再向左
要看到谁的粉碎多哒哒哒
嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒
换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒
嘿嘿嘿
有话要直说
让机会又擦肩溜走
遇见和你勇敢say
苍蝇电流在穿梭
哦哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒
晚上快乐舞步
哒哒哒
呦呦呦
为自己加油
小心放假
幸福等等我哦
恋爱节奏要天长地久
two three four
脚步别落空
哦
哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒
换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒
嘿嘿嘿嘿
等我来教授调侃
忧愁世界照亮过哦
a b c d答案是什么
这感觉不用想太多
oh da da da da da da d
哒哒哒
换上快乐舞步
起来嗨起来好不好啊
呦呦呦呦
让开心先过
晚上想搜寻好结果
oh向前向后转身
再向左
要烦恼谁的分最多
哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒
哒哒哒换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒
嘿嘿嘿
用未来招手
怎么唱啊
跳开忧愁
世界照亮过a b c d担心什么
这感觉不用想太多哦
哒哒哒嘟噜嘟噜嘟噜哒哒哒哒哒哒
换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒
哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒
哒哒
晚上快乐舞步
哒哒哒哒哒哒
4590bu
换上快乐舞步
哒哒哒哒哒噜噜噜哒哒哒哒哒哒
哒哒哒
谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢你们
啊啊say耶
老师跟我们一起
谢谢你
谢谢老师
谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢你们
谢谢拜拜
身边的朋友
我们要过去了
要跟你们说谢谢
谢谢你们
谢谢谢谢
龙真的
谢谢哇哈哈哈哈哈
谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢
谢谢真的要跟大家说再见了
谢谢晚安
谢谢
再次谢谢大家陪我到最后
谢谢拜拜
谢